bonsoir bienvenue pour le 7-8 lecture
sur tv fil 78 chaque soir de la semaine
à 18h bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition donc voici les principales
informations dans les yvelines en ce 25
septembre la verrière vient d'organiser
pour la première fois un forum de
recrutement avec uniquement des
entreprises locales avec un taux de
chômage dans la ville autour des 16 %
selon les derniers chiffres de l'insee
nous avons compris les résultats obtenus
offrir ou s'offrir les yvelines c'est
possible dorénavant un coffret
comportant des offres promotionnelles
vient d'être lancé par le conseil
général avec pour objectif d'attirer les
parisiens dans le département et puis
les échéphiles ce prêt style on court
pour assister aux prouesses des
pousseurs de bois comprenez les
meilleurs joueurs d'échecs s'affrontent
jusqu'au 5 octobre dans le cadre du
grand prix de paris le point sur les
résultats des français notamment avec
notre invité est le directeur général de
la fédération française des échecs on
commence journal comme chaque soir par
quelques images et la société nissan
west europe qui annonce l'installation
de son nouveau siège à voisins le
bretonneux au val saint quentin parc
d'affaires de plus de quarante et un
mille mètres carrés qui boucle ainsi sa
commercialisation est nissan a signé un
bail ferme de 6 ans et huit mois l'an
dernier la marque annonce avoir
commercialisé 109 mille véhicules dont
79 milles en france soit une part de
marché de 3 45% et nissan est ainsi la
première marque asiatique sur le marché
automobile français
rapprocher à les employés et les
employeurs c'est l'objectif du rendez
vous qui se donnait cet après midi à la
verrière est la commune vient
d'organiser son premier forum du
recrutement 100 % local yolande thorez
pour les précisions
cette jeune fille est venue avec ses
copines à la rencontre des entreprises
je suis en première année de licence
d'histoire en fait ils s'ennuient pas
trop en fait dont j'aime bien faire un
bts un bts ont tourisme c'est son
nouveau projet pour cela elle a besoin
d'une entreprise qui accepteraient de la
prendre en stage en alternance
-
apb admission postbac elle pourrait
passer si elles ne trouvent pas de
stages mais la jeune fille a surtout
retenu une chose qui lui redonne le
sourire on m'a dit que les bts s'il y
avait des des écoles qui prennent en
février qu'il faut des rentrants février
donc ça me laisse très bas à six mois
pour trouver un bts
c'est bien c'est donc plutôt rassurés et
motivés que l'étudiante sort de cette
rencontre jeunes entreprises une
rencontre à l'initiative du service
jeunesse de la mairie mais pas seulement
plusieurs jeunes actifs de la verrière
ont prêté main forte on sentait qu'il y
avait une vraie fracture entre ces deux
mondes on avait l'impression qu'il
n'était pas opposé mais que c'était
difficile
pour un jeune de banlieue de franchir
d'aller toquer à la porte d'un job
employeur lors de ces rencontres pas de
propositions d'emploi juste d échanger
des conseils individualisés mais
l'objectif est bien là un meilleur
accompagnement de ces jeunes diplômés
pourrait permettre par la suite
davantage de réussite al embauche
et puis quelques précisions concernant
les chiffres du chômage justement pour
la première fois depuis avril 2011 le
nombre de chômeurs a reculé en août
moins cinquante mille demandeurs
d'emploi à travers l'hexagone emploie
toujours et le gouvernement décidément
très présent dans le département ces
dernières semaines après un moment de
bourg et fleur pellerin elle en cours
dans les locaux de ads pour lancer le
plan de développement de l'industrie
française après marisol touraine et
michèle delaunay à la verrière à la mgen
pour l'ouverture des contrats d'avenir
au monde médico-social ce vendredi un
nouveau déplacement de ministres est
annoncée encore à la verrière pour la
signature toujours deux contrats
d'avenir françois lamy en charge de la
ville accompagné de benoît hamon en
charge de l'économie sociale par et non
de trois jeunes de la ville embauché en
tant que cadre de vie et auxiliaires de
vie nous y reviendrons plus en détail au
cours de nos prochaines éditions
offrir ou s'offrir le département vous
connaissez déjà le principe de ces
coffrets cadeaux qui regroupe des offres
promotionnelles et depuis hier est
arrivé sur le marché une y box y pour
yveline bien entendu et c'est le conseil
général qui est à l'initiative de cette
idée claire cambier patrick jacques de
dixmude
league grecque box est disponible dans
le commerce depuis mardi un coffret qui
regroupe 78 offres culturelles de
loisirs ou d'hébergement à prix bradés
ou 1 50% une vidéo telles visites de
musées ou encore paint ball il
s'agissait de de partir d'une réflexion
très simple qui était de dire
aujourd'hui d'être les gens partent
moins loin moins longtemps en vacances
proposons leur de redécouvrir ou de
découvrir tout simplement les yvelines
l'entreprise martèle qu est habitué aux
boks en tous genres mail y box et son
premier partenariat avec une
collectivité
l'initiative vient en effet du conseil
général qui espère booster le secteur du
tourisme on a fait le calcul à peu près
si les acheteurs les futurs acheteurs de
cet eee box
utilisent tout ce qui leur est offert et
ils font une économie de 3000 euros donc
vous voyez pour un investissement de
moins de 30 euros c'est une un bon
placement mais au delà de ça c'est bien
entendu destinée à mieux faire connaître
les yvelines dans le département le
tourisme reste en effet peu développée à
l'exception du site du château de
versailles ce projet de boxe est dans
les cartons depuis un an et demi il a
fallu dans un premier temps convaincre
les partenaires les hôtels qui assurent
principalement une clientèle d'affaires
en semaine ils y ont vu un moyen de
combler leur faible taux d'occupation du
week-end en moyenne moins de 50% donc
c'est une façon de bloquer dans les
yvelines
nous nos clients potentiels et siphonner
un peu paris qui qui attire vraiment
trop par rapport à lui leurs offres ne
sont disponibles que le week-end toutes
les activités du coffret peuvent être
utilisés une fois dans la limite d'un an
et peut-être allez-vous craquer pour
cette y boxe mais déjà êtes-vous
amateurs de ce genre de cadeau cela vous
semble qu'il intéressant un bon plan
tout simplement c'est notre question du
jour
berman a offert plusieurs fois oui c'est
pas mal surtout des boks bien-être voilà
pour des soins en institut ce genre de
choses oui le choix est un peu restreint
mais sinon j'ai toujours été satisfait
de la qualité on en a offert au mois de
décembre que j'ai toujours pas utilisé
parce que j'ai il faut il faut réserver
sur internet c'est assez compliqué donc
il faut prendre du temps mais j'avoue
que ça a l'air pas mal mais pour
l'instant on n'en sait pas encore servi
ce qui est compris dans le coffret ça
oblige à faire d'autres frais à côté que
certains n'osent pas n'osent pas faire
quoi donc c'est des fois
on se sent obligé d y aller parce que
c'est un cadeau qu'on nous a fait mais
c'est pas toujours
rentable pour certains certaines
personnes si derrière ça suit c'est à
dire si les gens se font par nac et sur
la non disponibilité des dates
si vous aussi vous reste que des dates
quand il pleut des cordes et qui fait
moins 20 alors que c'est une balade en
mer quoi c'est tout mais si si ça suit
bien moqué un bon concept c'est sympa
autre sujet ce mardi au lycée horticole
de tremblay sur mauldre les élèves se
sont réunis toute la journée au profit
des restos du coeur pour récolter des
pommes de terre pour la campagne
d'automne des restos dans les yvelines
une vaste opération de solidarité qui
est renouvelée à chaque année avec
toujours le même entrain pour ces jeunes
et pour leurs enseignants reportage
olivier maniscalco et jonathan vilma
ils ramassent des pommes de terre pour
les restos du coeur eux ce sont les
élèves du lycée horticole de tremblay
sur mauldre 150 apprentis c'est ap et
lycéens se sont relayés ce mardi sous le
soleil pour venir en aide aux plus
défavorisés
le but a provisionné la campagne
d'automne des restos et sensibiliser les
lycéens à une oeuvre caritative
la démarche a été initiée il ya déjà une
bonne dizaine d'années en partenariat
avec un maraîcher bio qui est juste
voisins à nos terres non seulement il ya
l'aspect de la sensibilisation au profit
d'une oeuvre caritative mais il ya
également tout l'aspect pédagogique par
rapport à la gestion de chantier les
jeunes arrivent ici il faut une
organisation il faut une méthodologie et
ça rentre pleinement dans l'organisation
des chantiers qui peut voir au travers
de leur formation peu fructueuse cette
année au vu des conditions climatiques
la récolte devrait avoisiner les 3
tonnes contre 7 l'an passé de quoi
alimenter tout de même durant deux
semaines la vingtaine de centres des
restos du coeur des yvelines
douze des meilleurs joueurs d'échecs du
monde ça frottements s'affrontent
pendant près de deux semaines à la
commanderie des templiers à elancourt
dans le cadre du grand prix de paris à
la clé deux places qualificatives pour
le tournoi des candidats dont le
vainqueur aura le droit à d'affronter le
champion du monde en titre pour
l'instant les deux représentants
français qui sont engagés dans la
compétition sont plutôt en bonne
position comme nous l'expliquent anthony
rech et elodie mois
après deux rondes sur les tables élan
courtoise laurent frayssinet a pris la
tête du tournoi avec une victoire et un
match nul le numéro 3 français le seul à
s'être imposés avec l'israélien boris
gelfand lors de cette sixième et
dernière étape du grand prix mondial à
31 ans il assume parfaitement son statut
de vice-champion d'europe 2012
c'est une très bonne expérience pour ses
excellents joueurs français d'affronter
les meilleurs joueurs du monde a strong
laurent frayssinet a déjà remporté une
partie très serrée face à alexander gris
chaud ce qui lui permet de prendre la
tête du tournoi et je pense que c'est
une belle récompense pour lui
mais lors de ce troisième match il aura
fort à faire face à l'italien fabiano
caruana troisième joueur mondial
de son côté l'autre français etienne
bacrot a déjà concédé deux matches nuls
le numéro deux tricolore a jusqu'au 4
octobre date de la fin du tournoi pour
débloquer son compteur victoire outre la
dotation de 120000 euros sur le tournoi
d'elancourt l'enjeu sportif est de
taille puisque les deux premières places
seront directement qualificatif pour le
tournoi des candidats 2014 dont le
vainqueur affrontera le champion du
monde en titre est l'invité de cette
édition c'est laurent vérat bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur général dtn de la
fédération française des échecs qui est
basé à elancourt justement à saint
quentin en yvelines on va parler de
cette compétition avec vous déjà les
résultats des français le reportage a
été réalisé à here en fin de journée on
faisait un petit bilan est ce
qu'aujourd'hui le classement un petit
peu changé comment se positionne ces
français une quatrième ronde aujourd'hui
qui encourt donc je peux pas vous dire
ce qui s'est passé parce qu'elle n'est
pas terminée ça s'annonce plutôt bien en
tout cas pour les français c'est les
numéros 2 et 3 dans le numéro un n'était
pas disponible une compétition encore
plus quand on ne part pas plus
importante mais enfin de très haut
niveau aussi pour laquelle il était
engagé depuis longtemps les français
oui ce qu'il faut préciser quand même
c'est que en réalité ils ne peuvent pas
se qualifier pour le toit des candidats
parce que ce tournoi fait partie d'un
grand prix organisé par la fédération
internationale sur deux saisons donc sur
deux années de l'année 2012 année 2013
et c'est sur l'ensemble des six tournois
du grand prix là c'est le sixième et
dernier au petit matin oui qu'on juge
les deux qui se qualifieront pour le
tourner les candidats même là s'ils
l'emportent ça veut rien dire parce que
ce sera la moyenne des autres rencontres
et six rencontres absolument qu'ils
peuvent plus ils peuvent plus prétendre
c'est un tournoi majeur qui est présenté
comme le grand tournoi de paris mais
nous sommes à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
plus précisément nous sommes à elancourt
pourquoi le grand tournoi de paris mais
en réalité la fédération internationale
qui est dirigée par une direction russe
pour elle ne le nom paris dans le pour
vivre dans laquelle ce tournoi devait
être organisée à l'origine
bombe à paris c'est paris et saint
quentin en yvelines où l encours s'est
pour sa part le moins et ça fait partie
de la région parisienne quand il
organisait la finale du championnat du
monde il ya deux ans à moscou pour le
monde entier est né à moscou en réalité
il était à 30 km de moscou donc voilà
internationalement elancourt saint
quentin en yvelines c'est paris c'est
mieux pour le prestige de mettre grand
prix de paris que vous imprimez
l'encours voilà quitte à vexer les
yvelinois et les lots pour toi
absolument mais à faire profiter tous
deux arrivent c'est un tournoi
d'envergure je le disais on peut quand
même insisté sur ça ça représente quoi
pour les gens qui ne sont pas habitués
aux échecs c'est des jeux olympiques
c'est une compétition mondiale non je
dirais que ça ressemble
c'est ce serait comme si on arrivait
directement en deuxième semaine de
roland garros
c'est un tournoi du grand chelem roland
garros avec seulement les 12 meilleurs
donc seulement à partir des huitièmes de
finale ou quelque chose de ce genre là
voilà en termes de niveaux ce que c'est
et qui est le favori alors qu'on la dit
les france a laissé deux favoris entre
les deux favoris c'est fabiano caruana
mon avis qui est numéro trois mondial
qui était numéro trois mondial le mois
dernier qui joue sa place
qualificatif pourtant à des candidats et
avec alexandre landry chouk qui lui
aussi s'est les deux qui seuls qui
peuvent encore se qualifier en réalité
pour le pour le prochain site de
championnat du monde il faut que l'un
des deux gagne le tournoi pour qu'ils se
qualifient donc et ils jouent ensemble
en ce moment et peut-être donc le futur
champion du monde est allé en cours en
ce moment alors c'est un peu compliqué
parce que le championnat du monde aura
lieu le mois prochain en inde entre
l'actuel tenant du titre anand est un
génie norvégien qui domine la planète
échec depuis trois ans dont on n'entend
pas encore beaucoup parler en france
mais qui a un charisme fou qui commence
à faire des émissions grand public qui
fait beaucoup de publicité des émissions
grand public en dans d'autres pays
occidentaux aux états unis magnus
carlsen est vraiment vraiment qui
dominent la discipline en ce moment
depuis trois ans et le champion du monde
attendra forte à faire le mois prochain
là on est en train de disputer les
qualificatifs pour le prochain
championnat du monde c'est à dire pour
chanter futur champion du monde aurait
peut-être celui qui pourra affronter
celui qui gagnera le match de
championnat du monde à nantes car la
scène du mois prochain qui s'annonce
comme un grand grand événement là par
contre sur le plan des échappements du
roman dur le tournoi qui se déroule
jusqu'au 4 5 octobre s'est ouvert au
public les partis seraient suivies aussi
sur le site internet de la fédération en
live on peut voir les joueurs
s'affronter faut être patient une partie
d'échecs c'est long si vous suivez ça
sur l'ordinateur fond de mettre dans un
coin de l'ordinateur au bureau forcément
le président de cette fédération
internationale était à elancourt le
président français également on va
l'écouter tout de suite il nous parle de
ce qui fait la différence pour
l'emporter sur un tel tournoi
voilà ça c'est une question très très
difficile il faut être en forme il faut
bien l'avoir préparé alors quelque chose
qui paraît surprenant pour pour les
sportifs de haut niveau c'est à dire
d'autres sports les échecs sont un sport
savoir une condition physique
exceptionnelle lors du l'événement garry
kasparov indique qu est ce qu il a fait
gagner
gros match c'est tout simplement une
meilleure condition physique que les
autres et c'est vrai que dans la
pratique ces joueurs là sont vraiment au
top niveau et s'entraîne donc font du
footing de la natation ont vraiment une
préparation il faut vraiment être bien
dans son corps pour bien jouer aux
échecs bien dans son corps c'est ça la
clé ont partagé la vie oui enfin c'est
une des clés absolument si jamais on est
absolument apa fit pas sur le plan
physique on peut pas excellé au meilleur
niveau mondial et que ça me présentant
ce parce que les journées s'enchaînent y
aura tout de même deux journées de repos
26 septembre demain donc appuyé le 1er
octobre également les joueurs vont se
reposer un petit peu il enchaîne comme
ça non stop les parties oui et puis ça
c'est la partie immergée un parti que
vous voyez pas c'est à dire dès qu'ils
ont fini taxi vers l'hôtel à versailles
et ils s'enferment dans leur chambre
d'hôtel il prépare la partie suivante on
s'est offert le match aussi plein
d'autres acteurs ils s'arrêtent un
projet thd et j'arrête avec la partie
qui est terminée comme n'importe quel
sportif qui oublie le match qui vient de
se conclure et qui pense déjà au match
suivant on peut déjà comme ça ceux
projetés et imaginer les coups qu'on va
tenter c'est que les combinaisons qu'on
veuille absolument on se prépare contre
l'adversaire du lendemain pourquoi vous
ne participe pas à ce tournoi bah
écoutez vous auriez bien aimé jordy
l'été il aurait fallu que je sois un
petit peu plus fort un petit peu plus
tôt me lancer vous avez là l'élite
mondiale quand même hein hays banque les
deux premières journées outre dans ce
cercle fermé de l'élite mondiale mais
par le travail dans le travail c'est un
vrai métier
complètement quoi on gagne sa vie en
jouant aux échecs et par contre derrière
il faut aussi une organisation peut
peut-être s'arrêter sur ça aussi parce
que c'est une lourde organisation ça
s'est décidé finalement assez
tardivement cette organisation serait en
cours comment vous avez géré tout ça ça
représente quoi c'est une grosse machine
oui c'est une assez grosse machine on
est un peu habitué lorsqu'on organise
les championnats de france qui sont des
mais c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
en championnat de france c'est un gros
événement sur une ville avec 1000
personnes 2000 accompagnateurs un
événement populaire et où là c'est un
événement d'élite c'est un petit peu
différent a en réalité et la fédération
internationale avait prévu d'organiser
ce tournoi à paris j'ai participé avec
la fédération internationale en juillet
ce sont des russes il faut dire ce qui
est et il organise tout en dernière
minute
et il avait prévu d'organiser ça à paris
et quand j'ai participé aux réunions de
préparation avec les organiser avec les
lieux au potentiel d'hébergement de
cette compétition mais ça n'a pas pu se
conclure et comme le président de la
fédération internationale qui l'ancien
président de la république de kalmoukie
une république tous russes qui siège à
la douma
qui fait qu est ce que je raconte qui
fait partie de la delà de la fédération
russe
avait entraîné les stratégies ça que je
dis là ils étaient venus ils étaient
venus à la commanderie il était venu
visiter le notre siège national ya
quelques semaines il avait
particulièrement apprécié le cadre et
c'est ça qui lui avait donné l'idée que
peut-être un jour un événement pourrait
se faire dans cette chapelle qui est
international d'ailleurs on l'a entendu
au début de cette semaine sur notre
antenne qui disait c'est comme l'un des
premiers événements qui sera organisé en
france sur paris sur la région on
ad'autres éventuellement aussi à venir
pourquoi pas oui enfin bon on va pas
organiser un évènement comme ça tous les
cas ce que ces cas là ce matin parce que
ça reste quand même un truc assez lourd
là les joueurs s'en décharger sur
versailles ce que vous nous disiez sens
versailles et tout son staff là qui gère
toute cette compétition qui se déroule
jusqu'au 4 octobre le 5 ce sera ensuite
pour la remise des récompenses pour ceux
qui suivent les parties forcément ils
sont habitués il ya tout un vocabulaire
qui va avec pour ceux qui connaissent
moins comme moi par exemple on va
peut-être faire un petit tour vous allez
nous expliquer un petit peu de mots de
vocabulaire alors qu est ce qu un
arriéré un pion arriérés un plus haut à
rien c'est un pion qui est qui et qui
reste en arrière et qui ne peut pas être
défendue par un autre pion un clouage un
clouage c'est une pièce cas pas le droit
de bouger parce que si elle bouge et
semelle mais son roi en échec c'est
compliqué fourchette également une
fourchette c'est une attaque simultanée
de deux pièces on va continuer comme ça
rock aussi le rock c'est un coup spécial
qui permet de mettre le roi l'abri et
ultimo par là par contre celui-ci
j'aurais du mal à le prononcer vous
allez sans doute me reprendre le sucre 0
le succès une situation qui arrivent
dans la vie c'est une situation où vous
êtes obligé de jouer si jamais vous
pouviez passer votre tour tout irait
bien mais comme vous êtes obligé de
jouer vous n'avez que le choix qu'entre
des mauvais coups et soutint vocabulaire
très spécifique un allez vous renseigner
si vous voulez suivre c'est parti tout
de même un tournoi international en
cours en ce moment vous pouvez le suivre
sauf demain puisque le 1er octobre
également il y aura le repos de ces
différents joueurs qui sont sans doute
déjà un petit peu fatigué qui vont
profiter de la journée de la journée de
demain je vous ai pas encore posé la
question est quel est le gain tout ça on
parlait de ces places qualificatives
pour tous les prochains tournois
mondiaux mais mais aussi un aspect
financier bah oui il ya cent vingt mille
euros de prix quand même et puis il ya
aussi les prix pour l'ensemble du grand
prix et encore je crois une dotation
bien plus importante pour rocky qui
vient qui vient gratifié les six
tournois qu'ils ont discuté en grèce en
chine en france et sur l'ensemble de
l'été années 2012 2013 là on est au
dernier donc on va pouvoir donner les
prix du grand prix oui ce sont des
joueurs professionnels qui gagnent leur
vie c'est pas encore les prix du tennis
mais enfin bon c'est sûr qu'il ait envie
demain journée de repos les joueurs vont
faire croire on disait c'est comme des
sportifs on en parlait tout à l'heure
voilà ils vont faire quoi ils vont aller
faire un footing ils vont répéter leurs
gammes sur des ordinateurs je pense que
chacun fera comme il veut moi je
l'aurais prévu une petite visite du
château de versailles vie privée la sig
et au risque de passer pour moi qu'il
ferait pleurer je leur ai organisé une
petite visite du château de versailles y
sont logés juste à côté donc ce serait
bête de ne pas en profiter de l'appui
ensuite retour à la compétition pour ces
sportifs on l'appelle ce sont des
sportifs de haut niveau qui pratiquent
les échecs merci à vous demain la
compétition repos mais en revanche elle
reprendra dès le lendemain pour se
terminer le 4 octobre et puis ensuite si
vous voulez encore suivre une autre
compétition d'échecs sachez qu'il y aura
aussi des rencontres d'un autre niveau à
montigny le bretonneux organisé par le
club de la dame noire qui fête son 25ème
anniversaire du 19 au 27 octobre vous
fait vous y inscrire aussi bien pour le
12e tournoi d'automne que pour disputer
la première édition du tournoi de
maîtres de compétition donc sur cette
période à suivre homologué d'ailleurs
par la fédération un mot peut-être sur
cette compétition ce sera d'un autre
niveau mais c'est aussi intéressant
c'est un tournoi de maîtres donc c'est
un échelon est évidemment bien inférieur
mais c'est les premières c'est le plus
début du niveau international donc ça
commence déjà à être ça commence a
commencé à jouer correctement ce sera
jusqu'au 27 octobre 19 au 27 octobre à
montigny le bretonneux pour l'instant
c'est à elancourt que cela se déroule
merci à vous le renverra nous allons à
présent revenir dans ce journal sur la
troisième édition du concours
international d'attelage de tradition
c'est un tout autre sujet qui s'est tenu
ce week end à rambouillet aurélia de
bissy elodie moines
chevaux voitures anciennes et meneurs
étaient en compétition ce week end dans
le parc du château de rambouillet
organisé depuis trois ans par le a un
national des bréviaires le concours
international d'attelage de tradition à
rayonner quarantaine de participants ces
collectionneurs de voitures anciennes
modèles d'époque de la fin du 19e ou
répliques fidèles sont notamment jugés
pour l'harmonie du couple cheval voiture
marché
atteint gens simples on perd en tandem
composé de chevaux de poneys et parfois
même dan quelle que soit la catégorie du
concours d'attelage de tradition reste
pour le meneur une vraie passion le
ménage permet d'avoir une équitation à
distance qui est absolument passionnante
et vous venez et voyez quatre chevaux
avec juste une main ou deux et vous avez
des sensations en suivant d'abord le
plaisir des fans et puis le respect de
la tradition parce qu'elles sont des
choses qu'on la transmettre aux
générations futures c'est très important
la france est un pays tellement
accueillants pour les contradictions on
y venir très souvent après trois
épreuves réalisées le jour la
présentation le parcours routier et la
maniabilité nos deux compétiteurs ont
chacun remporté un prix dans leur
catégorie
et pour un point complet sur la culture
n'oubliez pas la prochaine édition de
kiosques le magazine culturel de la
rédaction de tv films présentés par
aurélia 2 bis si on en revient à notre
image du jour nos images du jour la
société nissan west europe qui annonce
l'installation de son nouveau siège à
voisins le bretonneux au val saint
quentin un parc d'affaires de plus de
quarante et un mille mètres carrés qui
boucle ainsi sa commercialisation
la nissan west europe a signé un bail
ferme de 6 ans et 8 mois à l'an dernier
et la marque annonce avoir commercialisé
109 mille véhicules dont 79 milles en
france soit une part de marché de 3 45%
nissan est la première marque asiatique
sur le marché automobile français
rapprochez employés et employeurs c'est
l'objectif du rendez vous qui se tenait
cet après midi à la verrière la commune
vient de tenir son premier forum du
recrutement 100 % local yolaine thorez
pour toutes les précisions
cette jeune fille est venue avec ses
copines à la rencontre des entreprises
je suis en première année licence
d'histoire en tête il s'enfuit pas trop
en fait donc déjà mis à part un bts un
bts en tourisme c'est son nouveau projet
pour cela elle a besoin d'une entreprise
qui accepteraient de la prendre en stage
en alternance
si vous avez rien à dans le x 10 et
inscrivez vous
apb admission postbac elle pourrait y
passer s'ils ne trouvent pas de stages
mais la jeune fille a surtout retenu une
chose qui lui redonne le sourire on m'a
dit que les bts s'il y avait des des
écoles qui prennent en février qu'il
faut des rentrants février donc ça me
laisse pas six mois pour trouver un bts
c'est donc plutôt rassurés et motivés
que l'étudiante sort de cette rencontre
jeunes entreprises une rencontre à
l'initiative du service jeunesse de la
mairie mais pas seulement plusieurs
jeunes actifs de la verrière ont prêté
main forte on sentait qu'il y avait une
vraie fracture entre ces deux mondes on
avait l'impression qu'il n'était pas
opposé mais que c'était difficile
pour un jeune de banlieue de franchir
d'aller toquer à la porte d'un jeune
enfant
lors de ces rencontres pas de
propositions d'emploi juste d échanger
des conseils individualisés mais
l'objectif est bien là un meilleur
accompagnement de ces jeunes diplômés
pourrait permettre par la suite
davantage de réussite al embauche
fort de cette édition du journal du 25
septembre invité demain et demande la
panouse qui gère le parc de thoiry et
qui s'inquiète de la hausse de la tva de
7 à 10% au 1er janvier le direct ce sera
à 18h pour le replay rendez vous sur
notre site internet et puis n'oubliez
pas également les réseaux sociaux bonne
soirée